Hi, I'm Ray Meyers. I'm currently chief
architect at All Hands AAI, makers of
the leading open source coding agent
called Open Hands. But I'd like to talk
about something different today. And I'm
I'm proud to be presenting at the online
track for AI Engineer Worlds Fair, but I
feel like I've actually snuck in the
back door today because this is not an
AI talk. Perhaps this is not even a
programming talk. This is a talk about
empathy. This is a talk about listening
to each other. But if those things are
uncomfortable for you, don't worry
because we will have the pleasant,
comforting backdrop of AI and
programming.
For starters, let me take you through a
day in the life of an AI skeptic, which
is the role I so often find myself in.
What happens is someone will say
something provocative in public like you
may have seen uh the CEO of Enthropic
Dario Amade say a few months ago at uh a
Council on Foreign Relations interview.
Um many interesting things in in that
interview but a quote that we saw got
shared around a lot was in 12 months we
may be in a world where AI is writing
essentially all the code. Right now he's
speaking to a general audience. uh as
software engineers we hear a little bit
different uh when you're saying the part
about writing the code because we
understand that uh the job contains you
know other factors but regardless
um I posted a a friendly challenge in
response to that uh to do with like
could you replace the software in one
mainframe can we kill one mainframe even
how difficult is that right now with
these uh AI tools that are soon to
supposedly write essentially all the
code, right? Um, and the specifics of my
challenge are not really that that
relevant right now. Just over the past
two years, I have repeatedly said
different forms of this. LLMs, large
language models, break old code. I I say
that a lot because I think it is ignored
simply the importance of maintaining old
code and keeping it alive that already
is ignored and the extent to which uh
these AI tools are performing much
better on writing new code than in
editing code that already exists. I feel
like that's sort of doubly ignored as a
result. I feel like I raise pretty basic
questions and point out pretty obvious
limitations a lot of the time and get
somewhat extreme reactions honestly. You
know, I've been called a lite. I've been
told I have my head in the sand. I've
been told I'm missing the big picture.
In the case where I posted that
challenge, actually the the full quote
was, "I was completely missing the big
picture so much that it physically hurts
to read my post.
Um, and you know, if my posts have hurt
you, I'm I'm sorry. Um, it honestly it
doesn't feel good to be talked to in any
of these ways, right? So, you may have
had to feel that way at some point as
well, or maybe you've been told this.
You've been told that you'll be left
behind.
Um, I struggle with this one. Honestly,
I I feel that Left Behind is verbiage
better suited for, you know, some
post-apocalyptic
religious prophecy in the form of a Bem
movie franchise starring Kirk Cameron
than in some sort of nuanced technical
discussion. Um, I heard this one
recently from someone who um was saying
it with a straight face and is someone
whose work I I respect. You know, it
goes back a long time. They said
resistance is futile.
Again, I I cannot comprehend what would
make someone want to say things like
this. For all the money in the bank, do
you recall what that quote is from? Was
it from the hero of that story? No. It's
a quote from the Borg from Star Trek.
One of the most notorious villains in
the entire science fiction genre. If we
find ourselves quoting the Borg in
earnest,
maybe we should reassess what side we're
on. When Peard was captured and being
mind controlled by the AI, he said,
"Resistance is futile." as ludis. But
the real Pequard would never say
resistance is futile. Pequard would say
if you're on the side of truth, you
should resist to the last breath. He
embodied that again and again. Um, but
we need to breathe. Um, I'm responding
to emotionally charged rhetoric and now
I've just started spewing out my own
emotionally charged rhetoric in
response.
This is not helping me listen to these
people. They're they're they mean well.
you know, I've chosen to engage. I made
the decision to engage in these
conversations and I need to be able to
try to do that productively. I need to
be able to hear people out. I think we
need to back up and decide what are we
even talking about. It is something very
important. It makes sense that a lot of
us feel strongly about it, which then
leads to us being in conflict with each
other because we're we're pondering what
is the future of software? What is it
going to look like next? What can we
make it? I mean, that that is deeply
interesting. If there's one thing I am
grateful to AI for is probably uh even
more than the technology, the
opportunity for us to have all be thrown
into this one conversation about the
future of the craft. It's a very
difficult conversation to be in of late
and I'm going to try to make it a little
easier with this, but I think it is an
important one worth having. I've
identified six scenarios that seem to be
embedded in the views people have been
putting out over the last few years and
I'd like to share them with you for the
remainder of this talk. So, let's get
started. These are extreme completion,
the dev apocalypse, the abstraction
leap, uncharted waters, the review
economy, and the infinite pile of
garbage. We will discuss each of these
briefly.
Now, extreme completion is probably the
most conservative of these views because
it is is already happening. We can just
see it happen. There's no real doubt
about whether this one will happen. It's
just a matter of you know how much with
what impact and that is simply the um
autocomplete style editors like cursor
like GitHub copilot are just going to
continue to help us type more of the
typing and uh be a great convenience
right so in that scenario in extreme
completion our job doesn't fundamentally
change even as they progress to these
agents that can take a few more steps.
You can still have, you know, a fairly
extreme completion with it still needing
to be on an engineer's leash most of the
time such that you could argue our our
role is not changing like a great deal.
So, pretty much everyone agrees this at
least is happening and and is a somewhat
significant shift. Right? This is what
this looks like. If you're at this
conference, you've surely seen it. This
is an example of using the cursor IDE
which is a fork of VS Code with a lot of
AI uh features built in. So there's a
function called clean prime to remove
trailing whites space. And I've prompted
it here in this little popup thing that
happens when I uh hit control K. Make
the function clean prime prime to remove
both leading and trailing whites space.
And sort of based on that example, it's
going to make me another Haskell
function. Pop out. There it is. This is
pretty cool. By the way, the reason I
happen to pick the programming language
hasll for this example is that it has a
very uh strong typing system. I think
that type theory is a very promising
counterbalance to add more certainty
into the flow when we have the
uncertainty of of LLMs doing codegen.
Regardless, uh here's uh another example
that that is maybe a little more uh
where where we think things are going
where I have uh delegated an entire task
via Slack. So, I'm just in my work chat
here and this is a new experimental way
of interacting with the open hands
agent. I've said, "Hey, there's uh this
pull request here where I've added this
this thing to a log statement and
probably some other things ought to have
that too. could you just uh poke around
and and make a PR that's adding that
where where it ought to go, right? And
few minutes later, boom, comes back this
48 file poll request. Like this is
really cool. You showed this to me like
a couple years ago. I would know this is
unreal that we have this. Nonetheless,
it is a fairly discreet, you know, uh
task. Not a lot of quote unquote, you
know, thinking needed to be done here,
but there there's a lot of grunt work
that's that's been taken up by being
able to do stuff like this. This sort
of, you know, all-purpose tech debt dirt
shoveler. Really neat. Still, I file it
under extreme completion. Uh, it is on a
very short leash. A lot of expertise
still involved. Much more extreme is the
scenario of the dev apocalypse, the
developer apocalypse.
At least um that's what it is to us as
software developers. If you're not a
software developer, if you are dependent
on software developers, actually they
don't see this as an apocalypse at all,
right? They see this as the innovators
paradise scenario because they're no
longer dependent on us to bring their
ideas to fruition. It sounds very nice
from their point of view. And I I'll say
this even um though we we benefit from
this not happening at the moment um if
it actually is possible if we can
deliver it I think it is desirable like
we should do that. I think really that
would be programming fulfilling its
destiny. It would be finishing the
project of computer science. You know
the objection to it wouldn't be this
isn't desirable. I think the objection
would be it's not feasible to do. But of
course, because of these different
incentives, someone who sees us
objecting to it can always say, "Hey,
you just want to keep your job." And
like, I do want my friends to keep our
jobs, right? Of course, I want that. But
I just don't think that's why I'm saying
the things that I'm saying about um how
some of these these solutions look
unsustainable. you know, I I think we
have real expertise that these critiques
come from. So, if you're going to
predict the dev apocalypse, uh you still
must say how we are going to get there,
right? And abstraction leap is one of
those ideas. It has a few flavors I'll
talk about. But basically, if you're a
believer in abstraction leap, you think
that what we currently think of as code
will no longer be the uh kind of level
of abstraction, the the substrate in
which we do our main work. uh doing
something like Java code or or Rust code
today, you know, that that will
eventually be in the position of
assembly language or JVM byte code or
LLVM bit code or something to that
effect. Only highly specialized people
would need to do that. Most of us can
just live up here uh doing something
more uh pleasant and and productive,
whatever that may be. But internally
it's ultimately codelike a as we
currently understand it right. So how
does that happen? One way people say
this will happen is with the prompts as
code flavor of the scenario as I call
it. So natural language instead of
source code becomes the main humanfacing
artifact that we manipulate. So how does
that scale? Well, maybe it gets some
kind of structure, right? Maybe there
are a bunch of little requirements
inside uh folders that are
interconnected. I don't know. It it is
structured somehow. It is tested
somehow. The objection to this other
than maybe uh you know vagueness would
be predictability. There is serious
reason to doubt that LLM prompts
constitute an abstraction, at least as
far as something that you're able to
really build on because uh of how
unpredictable it is. Perhaps in order to
build really large longived projects, uh
this just is not a sturdy enough
foundation. It's not a clean
abstraction.
You could say that it will become one.
um we have to see that happen or you
know some people believe that it's
possible to make up for that
unpredictability with some sort of
control.
Here's an attempt to do this right. This
is actually from uh a few years ago now,
the parcel paper and you can go to this
uh GitHub repo if you like or you can
read the the the paper and this is an
example for instance where they've got
61 lines of just these text prompts and
example input and output of all these
different functions and from these uh
prompts and examples it generates a
220line
Python program that functions as a lisp
interpreter. Right? So they've using
these structured prompts generated
entire list interpreter like that that's
pretty neat right um and yet you know we
largely don't believe structured prompts
as code as a way to build real
applications h is a solved problem still
uh so you know when you try to
operationalize this are we going to be
able to make this into a a real product
that is better than its alternatives I
think very much still up in the air
another flavor of abstraction leap I
think personally is a little more
promising is domain specific languages
or DSLs. Now, if you believe you're
unfamiliar with DSLs, actually you
probably are familiar with them because
in programming there there are many of
them that that occur, right? So, uh CSS,
right? The that you use to style web
pages are an example or SQL queries or
regular expressions, right? And these
are domain specific languages for
particular programming tasks. And then
you also have ones that are made for
particular business domains even things
like Excel uh you know arguably are a
domain specific language. So the these
are very prolific, very successful often
times. Um and what you do if you're
operationalizing this, you know, in an
enterprise scenario is you ultimately
are investing in creating a particular
specialized programming environment that
you know optimizes for the kinds of
thoughts you usually need to express in
your business domain, right? And uh that
is this upfront investment that can
yield great reliability, great quality,
uh great productivity, you know, when it
works well. And it can also backfire of
course. And over the last 20 years, the
um kind of riskto-reward
trade-off has been steadily improving
with lots of tooling that's made it
easier to create these specialized
environments such such as language
workbenches, right? So uh examples of
that are uh Jetrains MPS right um one
called Lion Web, one called XExt,
there's one uh you could call it a
language workbench. They would say it is
a languageoriented programming
environment called racket which is very
interesting lisp dialect.
And there is every reason to believe
that language models in various ways
would even further improve the cost uh
you know riskreward tradeoff of creating
these these specialized environments.
Can they help us generate, you know,
some of the code to process these DSLs
or can they help on the uh side of the
editor giving the the, you know,
business domain users suggestions to to
allow them to more quickly adapt to
these languages. So, um I think this is
a very promising area. I've actually
declared it the year of DSLs on my
YouTube channel, Craft versus Craft. on
the right you can see uh my announcement
of that. It was a recent video. If you
want to dive a little deeper or better
yet, you could watch this talk called
empowerment of subject matter experts by
uh DSL afficionado Marcus Volter. But
again, an abstraction leap scenario.
Ultimately, what's underneath that
abstraction is still fundamentally
codelike. It is still basically
following the rules as we understand
them today. Next, we have uncharted
waters. Many people argue that the
future the foundation will not even be
codelike. It will be like nothing we
have seen before.
So what does that mean? Um some say that
it will be direct model inference. So
you will be not just using LLMs in code
or using LMS to code but LLM will be
like the processors themselves. that
model inference will simply be the new
computation. Um or maybe the AI becomes
super intelligent and it invents a new
programming paradigm we can't even
conceive of right and um I don't know uh
I think uncharted waters are certainly
possible but in order to plan for them
in order to take these possibilities
seriously we need to chart them we need
to really see what works and what really
scales right and I I don't think we've
um we've seen anything like this really
prove out yet.
Getting back to the mundane, we have the
next to last scenario, the review
economy. Right? So in this one, this is
created for instance by the extreme
completion.
And we have very cheap to create all
these pull requests like the one I
generated, you know, in that in that
previous slide. and we're still stuck
checking their output because they're
not good enough to just completely
approve. So ultimately we are just
reading pull requests from these AI
slinging them at us. You know many
people find this to be kind of a dismal
scenario like the least fun part of the
job has just become our whole job. Kind
of depressing. I don't see this so much
as an endgame, but maybe it will be a
pit stop. There are certainly companies
that have already seen, you know, this
is some kind of reality, but I think
it's a pit stop along to something
better. I think it is a sign that you're
not managing your bottlenecks. Well, pro
tip, there's a body of knowledge called
theory of constraints
um introduced by Ellie Goldrath starting
in the uh novel the goal, but there's a
lot of work in it sense. But the
thinking processes in theory of
constraints are really helpful whenever
you're in some situation that it looks
like this, right? Where everything's
held back by this one choke point, like
in this case, manual developer review.
Examples of what uh you know improving
that can look like are shifting further
left like I mentioned with type theory
like any number of of things. How can we
reduce the error rate such that we're
less bound by uh needing to review
these? Or maybe it's just a matter of
prioritization. Maybe we need to pick
and choose which of these things we're
even going to try to review. And you
know, by shipping a third of those
items, we get 90% of the value because
we're doing a good job of picking the
the right ones, the ones that that that
really are going to give us something.
Last scenario, and the most dismal, is
the infinite pile of garbage. In this
scenario, coding assistance made us feel
more productive, but ultimately just
exploded tech debt and dug us into a
hole that even the AI could not dig us
out of. The quality of our products gets
worse over time instead of better. Uh,
ultimately, it's a world of hurt. We
hope that this doesn't happen of course
and there's reason to think it may
already be starting to happen. This is
for example um a group called uplevel
which did some investigation in which
they did this controlled trial and they
found that developers who had access to
a coding assistant were uh putting out a
significantly higher bug rate and and
not even having better throughput on
their issues. That's pretty dismal.
Getclear also has a white paper and they
have a number of interesting things in
that. One of which is that this was the
first year 2024 this past year was the
first year they've seen where the
percentage of code that was copy pasted
exceeded that which was moved in a
refactoring. If you know your way around
code quality that's a big red flag. Lots
of copy and paste creates a lot of risk.
Some people could argue that with these
AI tools, the practices, our intuition
for for what is a good thing or not may
need to change, but that needs to be
borne out. You need to prove that.
Unsurprisingly,
GitHub actually had the opposite
finding. They did not find that their
co-pilot tool that they sell um
decreases quality. They found that it
increases it. Now they were doing a
controlled experiment involving a fixed
task. It was not like these other
examples um you know an example on on
real work code but there's any number of
factors that could impact this. So they
uh have a blog u does get copile improve
code quality admittedly much better
graphic design they say yes it does. So
what do we make of this? I mean these
results are obviously you know
contradictory and ambiguous but you know
even more importantly they're all from
sources that have something to sell. You
know I I have seen some more rigorous
academic work start to come together. I
would love next year to be talking about
not some white papers and a blog but you
know uh maybe a metaanalysis
of multiple different you know
independent academic studies of uh what
results we have in the wild with AI
coding assistance. Will we be able to to
do that? I mean I hope so. But one way
or another, you know, um, do these make
things better under certain
circumstances and worse under other
circumstances? Does it matter how we use
them? Does it matter what we use them
on? These are all things we need to
understand so that we know we're making
the situation better and not worse.
People will say the models will get
better, but the products we use them to
build will get better only if we make
them better. We need to be deliberate.
Again, these are the scenarios. Extreme
completion, deocalypse, abstraction
leap, uncharted waters, review economy,
and infinite pile of garbage. Now, these
interrelate in various ways, right? So
for example by doing extreme completion
many fears as I just mentioned that we
will try to get to dev aocalypse but
actually we will overinvest in them
before we are capable of dealing with
their results and we'll slide right past
devocalypse and into the infinite pile
of garbage. Some think this is maybe the
closest to my point of view that a
really promising area would be to
combine abstraction leap with maybe
domain specific languages. Combine that
with the extreme completion. We have a
very nice u DSL or say a formal methods
uh based you know specification system
and then we combine that with the
extreme completion to you know you know
help us navigate it ergonomically. This
could work very well. So there are these
multiple different endgames and if
someone believes in a different one as
you, you might both be right because
many of them are going to play out. The
industries are vast. This is going to um
impact different areas very differently.
We wouldn't expect the uh AI coding
impact on like video game programming to
be the same as in healthcare tech,
right?
And lastly, I want to leave us with
this. We get a say. People have spoken
about AI coding as though it is some
meteor from outside the solar system
just coming at us to hit us and we're
these these passive observers. We get a
say on what happens. This is something
that we are actively building together.
So I think we need to ask ourselves what
do we want from software?
What is the goal? Do we want there to be
no programmers or do we want everyone to
be a programmer? I don't think those are
the same thing. Is it somewhere in
between where uh do we want software to
be better of higher quality or do we
just need more software and we don't
care about the quality? Again, not the
same thing as the skills required to do
our jobs change. What do we want to
happen? Do we think it's a good idea to
just let people go who have diligently
learned what yesterday was the thing we
needed or are we going to figure out how
to continue to develop a valuable
relationship with those people? I want
many things from software. I want it to
work well. I want it to provide value
for the people who use it and for the
people who build it. And I want people
who work together to treat each other
well.
Well, thank you very much for having me
and I look forward to your questions.